[Music]
if he isn't there he can't smell your
hair
it must it must be time to set our
clocks back or
change the water filter because sleepy
joe biden is addressing the press again
you've noticed president biden's had one
news conference in 83 days
to put that in perspective that's 83
mayfly
life spans
also he barely tweets not even his
old-timey insults from the campaign
trail
when he called people dog-faced pony
soldiers or lily-livered flop doodles
and other sick burns from the civil war
era
it's so different from the joe we used
to know the electrifying speaker who
plagiarized
from only the best these days were on
the edge of our seats waiting for the
man
who could barely stand up from his
he hasn't done interviews he makes
speeches but usually on the teleprompter
well politico says that's the strategy
and it's awfully suspicious
that biden's team openly admits it's
better if he doesn't talk
and when they're not talk taking turns
hiding joe's car keys
the white house communications team is
relying on cabinet secretaries to talk
policy
unless it's to a world leader kamala
handles those
and they answer the tough questions
early on a sunday morning while joe has
some cocoa
and does the jumble which oddly makes
sense to him in the original form
and then he calls it a knight when the
rest of us are calling at 3 p.m
it feels weird to have a president that
doesn't engage with the press
i mean after four years of this
i just told him i've got to come over
and see the fake news let's go
right now what do you say to americans
who are watching you right now who are
scared
uh i say that you're a terrible reporter
that's awesome
mr president my second question that's
enough thank you very much
please please that's enough
between you people don't answer don't
talk to me that way you're just
you're just a lightweight don't talk to
me that way don't talk to i'm the
president of the united states don't
ever talk to the president that way
it never gets old maybe joe biden saw
how the press treated trump and thought
i don't want to talk to them either
right joe
i don't need to talk to the press all
day i don't like to talk anyway i'm a
good
listener ask dr jill
she knows and i keep up with what's
going on i know the news i got the
the the phonograph on the the the record
player
anything else i leave it to george
pataki
jen uh basaki she's good
she was governor new york before that
cuomo guy
he had a good run i told him don't
squeeze the charmin
[Laughter]
laura do you miss it i mean are you when
you were watching
when you watched the before and after is
it's pretty stark
i mean how boring is everything now and
and we knew this was gonna happen i mean
look whether you loved president trump
or you hated him
he was the most transparent president in
a long time that america has seen
you saw him he used to love to walk out
there and all right let's go the fake
news
everybody loved that and now we get
nothing from joe biden i mean he can
barely get through
these teleprompter speeches i wouldn't
even call it a press conference so
so much that he's had but uh how boring
it's just really kind of sad
you know what a cat you know what it
reminds me of trump was just like the
guy
in the first block talking to cnn that's
why everybody liked it
because he would get in the breath he
would just he would just go oh it's
tired of this
he would just start swearing it was not
swearing but it was like that's what we
needed
look i i don't understand and i have the
common narrative of
people is oh i'm so i'm not worried
anymore now that
biden is the president and i don't have
i'm not hearing anything crazy and i
don't understand having that mindset
that if you don't know or see something
that nothing bad could be happening
yes i prefer bad or good
the more that we know allow me to at
least
know what to be upset about right
although i'm just blanket upset at
everything
biden is like a pug's fart
silent silent but deadly
i mean look he's a bit matt he's like
i'm not following you just give it to me
one more time
you can borrow my french bulldogs okay
all dogs tend to just explode yes
but my point is this is that we've been
trained to think that joe biden is this
kindly
old gentleman but he's a vessel for the
most progressive politics
and they're sliding right through by the
way he was never that kind he's been at
this game
a long time talked to people like
clarence thomas and others he's been a
pretty ruthless politician
look people said what was going on in
the trump white house was crazy
let me tell you that was the most honest
moment we've had in politics in a long
time
this is crazy we have a president who
gets handed cards
yes and you know you're doing a pretty
good job with what you're doing over
here with the camera but he's having
some trouble over there with trying to
read what this is yeah oh i'm supposed
to speak now i mean
i actually have to say this i have
compassion for his performance because
i'm like
let him go home let him take a nap let
him
that's enough we get it you know send
the staff out there to make the
announcements i think
it's better yeah when i'm that age i'm
home
in a in bed watching forensic files
until i collapse
i'll be dead well you will tyrus you
know i don't think that biden's strategy
is that bad
it's exactly what my wife does when she
has friends over she always
makes tells me to go somewhere and just
stay away
and it and and she she never tells me
why
but she says you know i'm having friends
well after the show i'll explain to you
why right i i really feel that
this is not biden's plan i feel like
he's being held hostage
because he's probably thinking if i'm
not out mixing it up and talking
and getting my point across and my
agenda how am i ever going to get
reelected and this team's like
uh and no one's told him yet
you know you know like i let me i got
this guys i'll go ahead you know i'm a
talker i can do
yeah we'll just talk to the script
please sir he asks
can i take questions i don't have the
end oh and then they show him a picture
of the shepherd the shepherd gets it if
you talk right
there well i've seen this a million
times they're leaking on
stories about the shepherd the shepherd
has to go to school now
like that's the hostage that's what he's
wrapping him up with like
you do what we say and the dog doesn't
get it
i had a similar experience with a german
shepherd okay
not the dog i spent some time in the
woods
[Laughter]
call me hans